buying Twitter might be the worst thing
to ever happen to Elon Musk but the best
thing to happen to people who love crazy
lawsuits and now Elon is suing the
lawyers who forced him to follow through
with the sale because he thinks that
they charge Twitter too much to beat
Elon Musk because now Elon owns Twitter
and he's the one that effectively has to
pay for it you really can't make this up
but of course it's more complicated than
that now apparently musk is still
smarting from the time that he was
forced to honor his deal to buy Twitter
for 44 billion dollars so now he has
filed a lawsuit against the law firm of
Wachtel Lipton Rosen and Katz the law
firm which represented Twitter when the
old owners sued musk to follow through
with the sale wattel charged Twitter 90
million dollars to facilitate the deal
that eventually led to musk taking
Twitter private now the old Twitter
board paid 84 million dollars right as
the deal closed literally 10 minutes
before the company turned over to musk
and now Elon would like all of that
money back please
now to review this was a sale between a
public company and an individual who
intended to take the company private
musk offered Twitter a share price of
54.20 per share and Twitter's board
accepted the deal musk then tried to
back out of the deal for reasons
relating to him being a huge idiot and
essentially musk failed to do his due
diligence before making the offer and
later realized that his offer was way
too high or maybe it dawned on him that
trying to make Twitter profitable was
going to require a lot more than just
chat posting on Twitter so he tried to
get out of it now walktail wasn't
Twitter's original Law Firm for the sale
but when musk said that the deal was
dead and tried to back out Twitter
turned to this Law Firm which has a
reputation as one of the world's top law
firms specializing in mergers and
Acquisitions I'm into uh murders and
execution mostly walks held properly
sued musk in the Delaware Court of
Chancery and he backed down without even
getting a discount on the original sale
price basically they spanked him now
right before the deal closed Twitter
paid the law firm 90 million dollars in
success fees Elon Musk believes that
this is unjust enrichment and the firm
should give most of that back to Twitter
which he now owns and the timeline
breaks down like this Twitter hired
Wachtel on June 21st 2022. the law firm
sent an engagement letter stating it
would represent Twitter quote on an
hourly fee basis in a litigation to
compel specific performance of the musk
parties acquisition of Twitter this
engagement letter doesn't contain any
language about a success fee now the
engagement letter indicates that Wachtel
negotiated an exemption from Twitter's
usual fee arrangement with outside
counsel which gave Twitter a 15 discount
on hourly billing rates and in the
months of work after making this
arrangement with Twitter Wachtel invoice
Twitter for a total of 18 million
dollars including 15.6 million dollars
in hourly fees musk characterizes that
as outrageous because it was only for
for a few months of work now what the
complaint leaves out is that during
those few months walks hell filed a
lawsuit against musk that successfully
compelled him to go forward with the
sale and the lawsuit was filed on July
12 2022 by October 4th 2022 musk gave up
his fight to back out of the sale and he
agreed to abide by the deal's original
terms and the closing was set for
October 28th now according to the
complaint on October 27th with quote the
firm's work on the merger litigation in
the Delaware Chancery Court already
concluded and without any foreseeable
need for Twitter to utilize its services
again Wachtel the law firm decided to
milk the company for 90 million dollars
in success fees musk says quote in other
words Wachtel sought and obtained a
success fee that resulted in a total fee
nearly six times its 15.6 million
dollars in invoiced hourly fees for a
few months work even though one it was
not called for by any prior agreement
with Twitter and two the litigation in
which Wachtel represented Twitter had
been stayed for weeks in anticipation of
just missile following the closing now
you might be asking why a success fee is
even a thing and why a company would
agree to pay a success fee over hourly
billing well many clients are concerned
that outside law firms run up billable
hours by overstaffing cases with too
many lawyers or generating work that
isn't necessary and the theory goes that
if you align the financial incentives of
the client in the law firm the law firm
is less likely to do a bunch of
unnecessary work and waste the client's
money and Bloomberg reports that wattel
was quote one of the first law firms to
link its fees to the value of successful
deals rather than linking them to hourly
billing rates like many of its peers and
in this way the law firms are acting
more like Banks which tie their fees to
a percentage of the deal when it's
completed and the exhibits attached to
the complaint include a memo from
Wachtel explaining the quote while our
fees are not based on the amount
involved in a matter experience
indicates that merger and acquisition
and takeover fees have typically ranged
from one percent or more on matters
under 250 million dollars and point one
of one percent or less on matters over
25 billion Wachtel argues that the value
of its advice can't be demonstrated by a
simple hourly rate
it's a classic line from lawyers
absolutely always the case I'm like a
god in human clothing lightning gold
shoes from my fingertips but the
difference here is that waxel didn't
start out the engagement with a success
fee specified and must complaint is that
it was improper for waktel to switch
from an hourly billing arrangement to a
success fee structure on the eve of
closing yeah this is one of those cases
that's going to be really fun to watch
because at the end of this case at least
one of these parties is going to lose
now musk's first claim is for unjust
enrichment he claims that the closing
day letter agreement between the board
of directors and the law firm quote
called for payment of an unconscionable
fee and was an unconscionable agreement
musk argues that Twitter's board of
directors were a bunch of losers who got
totally hosed by the law firm the
complaint describes them as quote lame
duck fiduciaries Who quote lost their
motivation to act in Twitter's best
interests during the sale the one would
argue here the complete opposite that
the board was in fact extremely
motivated to close the sale at the
original price which arguably was in the
best interest of the shareholders but
musk perspective is that it was clearly
not in Twitter's best interest to have
paid this enormous legal bill but that
misunderstands what their duties
actually were between signing and
closing their legal fiduciary duty was
to make sure that the deal maximized the
value for Twitter shareholders that's
all they had to do and the lame duck
fiduciaries executed that responsibility
beautifully by forcing musk to buy
Twitter at an extremely high share price
and if they accomplished that then the
shareholders didn't care what else
Twitter did with its money because it
was no longer theirs and in fact because
the share price was already set by Elon
Musk it didn't really matter how much
they paid out to the lawyers because
that wasn't going to change how much the
shareholders ultimately got though it
really made a big dent in Elon musk's
pocket when he had to pick up the pieces
of Twitter when he bought it and yes 90
million dollars is a lot of money but
were the lawyers fees beyond the pail in
this particular case well in contract
law if the terms of a contractor unfair
or oppressive to one party in a way that
suggests abuse during its formation a
court can find it unconscionable and
refuse to enforce it but courts rarely
find unconscionability in the business
dispute between two fairly equal parties
a contract is most likely to be found
unconscionable if both unfair bargaining
and unfair substantive terms are shown
and generally courts only void a
contract on unconscious middle grounds
in extreme cases there's one famous case
where a loan interest rate was 800
percent or an instance where a warranty
expires before a product is even
installed basically things that really
shock the conscience not really things
like a relatively High bill for
litigation that won billions of dollars
but you know your mileage may vary now
speaking of great lawyers my firm the
eagle team is now accepting new clients
and we don't charge 90 million dollars
if you've been in a car crash of data
breach or medical malpractice or just
about anything else we can represent you
or help find you the right attorney who
can just click on the link in the
description for a free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you need the eagle team the
link is down below and now back to Elon
Musk now waktel is one of the Premier
mergers and Acquisitions firms and its
Partners make serious Bank by charging
success fees and in the firm's fee
Arrangement memo Wachtel outlined his
comparables explaining that its success
fees generally range from 67 to 100 of
the investment banking fees and the memo
also says that the fee could be a
multiplier of its hourly billing or run
rate and during the first four months
the lawyers billed 26.6 million dollars
and the success fee is about 2.5 times
that amount which was within comps
wattel gave to Twitter and the banks JP
Morgan and Goldman Sachs got 133 million
with 113 million of that as a success
fee when the buyout closed so the 90
million dollars that musk complains
about was around 68 percent of the
bankers fees which is actually on the
lower end of comparables if you are to
believe waktel but musk argues that the
success fee is too much because
litigation didn't move forward and
walkedel wasn't the law firm involved in
the original negotiation between musk
and Twitter and that's in argue document
but it's probably not particularly
strong to prove his point musk states
that the work that the lawyers did
wasn't particularly hard since it was
just a garden variety contract dispute
quote there were no novel or difficult
questions of law involved nor did the
litigation require any special skills
beyond that which Twitter could have
procured by paying hourly rates to many
other reputable law firms with the
experience litigating in the Delaware
Chancery Court including those hired to
work alongside Wachtel now this argument
is particularly hilarious because musk
is actually admitting that the legal
questions weren't that difficult because
he really didn't have any legal basis
for backing out of the deal basically
that his litigation was frivolous and if
musk had simply done what he was
supposed to do by consummating the deal
in the first place Twitter wouldn't have
to pay a success fee at all and of
course Twitter's board was obviously
pleased that Wachtel helped to close the
deal at the original price and if
Twitter had renegotiated the deal so
that musk had to pay a lower share price
the shareholders would have lost billion
millions of dollars far more than the 90
million dollars that they paid in the
lawyer fees and the deal of course
closed at 44 billion dollars which means
that the success fee wound up being
about 0.2 percent of uh that eventual
deal so yeah it's arguable that the
success fee helped Twitter save a lot of
money and the board probably feels
pretty good about it and in fact
successities are so normal with mergers
and Acquisitions that musk's own Law
Firm read Collins and PSY the lawyers
handling this case for him also charge
them but on the other hand it's possible
that musk has a reasonable argument here
he argues that the success fee is
unconscionable in part because the
firm's work had already been done
therefore there couldn't be an
enforceable contract to pay effectively
an additional 90 million dollars because
again the work had already been done now
consideration in contracts refers to the
benefit that each party receives in
exchange for what it gives up for a
contract gratuitous promises AKA gifts
are not enforceable so a promise to let
someone borrow your car is not
enforceable but a promise to let someone
borrow your car in exchange for a
hundred dollars absolutely is and
similarly if you want to modify an
existing contract you need some new
consideration generally speaking in
order for that modification of the
contract to stick consideration can be
big or small as long as the parties
mutually agree to exchange something
between themselves and right now all the
lawyers watching this video are shouting
the word peppercorn at the screen
because in law school you learn that
consideration can be something as small
and insignificant as an actual
peppercorn though these days that is a
metaphor for just something that is very
small that you're you're giving up now
this could be a good argument for musk
in the original fee agreement Twitter
agreed to pay the law firm for services
that would be billed hourly and at the
last minute Twitter agreed to pay 90
million dollars for a success fee and
it's possible that this was improper a
fee agreement needs to spell out the
services that a lawyer is performing for
the client outline the type of fees that
it will charge and give the client an
idea of how much they can expect to pay
and in this case musk has a point that
Wachtel can't change the original terms
of the agreement without consideration
so how might walk towel defend itself
well Joe Patrice over it above the law
suggested that from wachtel's point of
view this wasn't changing the terms of
the original agreement per se he
suggested The Firm might have been quote
opening new talks on the comprehensive
fees involved in both litigating and
Advising on a deal and under this Theory
Wachtel concluded that its role in
litigation was complete as most said but
that they needed a new arrangement to
compensate The Firm for its role in
advising Twitter during closing and
that's definitely a possibility but so
far we don't know if that's what Wachtel
and the old Twitter owners were actually
thinking and we certainly don't know
waktel's side of the story or the old
Twitter boards side of the story Wachtel
could legitimately argue that it had to
advise the company on any last minute
maneuverings by musk and that work
providing advice to Twitter before the
deal closed could constitute
consideration and again getting 90
million dollars for providing a little
bit of advice seems exorbitant but
legally the consideration can be almost
anything of value and consideration will
only be considered inadequate if it's
really worthless but right now we're
only privy to the allegations of the
complaint and the exhibit so it's very
likely that there is a lot more relevant
Communications here than what was
attached to the complaint though
additionally Elon Musk says that the fee
violated the ordinary course Covenant
that was found in the merger agreement
He suggests that Twitter employees
including the outgoing board of
directors were up to corporate sabotage
the complaint says that quote fully
aware that nobody with an economic
interest in Twitter's Financial
well-being was minding the store waxel
arranged to effectively line his pockets
with funds from the coming to cash
register well the keys were being handed
over to the musk parties but remember
Twitter had to hire Wachtel because Elon
was trying to get out of the merger
agreement in the first place and musk
complains that right before the deal
closed these stupid people met to
approve the fee request despite a musk
directive to Halt all payments quote the
closing day directive was an unequivocal
statement on behalf of Twitter's
residual claimants of the corporation's
preference to pause outbound payments
pending that day's closing so that the
company's new owner could have a
reasonable opportunity to review such
payments so musk is arguing that they
shouldn't have approved the fee in part
because he had no intention of paying
the bills that Twitter already owed but
the company didn't have to follow elon's
directive until he actually owned the
company and not a moment before so
Twitter paid the fee right before the
deal closed like literally minutes
before the deal closed and musk thinks
that this timing is nefarious and that
they intended to keep the payment secret
and now it's true that Twitter
Executives didn't have much incentive to
pay the lawyers the lowest fees that
they could get away with but on the
other hand they also weren't sure that
the deal would close until the day that
it actually did so if the Twitter
Executives made too many crazy decisions
that cost the company tons of money
they'd be screwing themselves over if
musk decided to litigate instead of
closing because they'd need to run a
company that was seriously hampered by
all the bad deals that they did but
there's also the fact that musk has a
long history of stiffing people he owes
money to and relying on your personal
history of breaking contracts seems like
a weak argument so musk would have been
in a much better spot if he claimed that
the 90 million dollars in fees was
outside the ordinary course of business
and refused to move forward with the
sale with that payment in place but of
course he famously moved forward with
the deal and paid 44 billion dollars and
now proudly owns a company that's worth
a fraction of that so maybe instead of
hiring yet more lawyers Elon should sit
back and enjoy a delicious meal
delivered straight to his door which you
can get with today's sponsor Factor
because Factor makes meeting your
nutrition goals easier than ever by
delivering fresh never Frozen dietitian
approved meals right to your doorstep
and the meals are completely ready to
eat eliminate the hours it would take to
shop meal prep and cook so you can spend
your day doing the things that you
actually want to do factory meals arrive
pre-prepared and ready to eat in just
two minutes in the same time I could
even think about going to the grocery
store my Factor meal is already done and
sometimes I just want a good healthy
meal without having to cook and it's
surprisingly affordable too Factor's
team of gourmet creates each meal using
only ingredients with Integrity to help
you feel your best all day long and they
really are extremely delicious like
Green Goddess chicken and grilled
Steakhouse filet mignon ready in just
two minutes the menus are updated weekly
with 34 different options so you can
choose your favorite meals or let Factor
craft your order based on your taste
preferences and meal history so give
factor a try by heading to factor75.com
and use the code legal eagle 50 to get
50 off your first Factor box or just
click on the link that's on screen or
down in the description and use the code
legal eagle 50 to get 50 off your first
Factor box and after that click on this
box over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court